whether he likes it or not Lionel Messi
is the focus for most camera lenses when
Argentina hit the training ground
competing at his last World Cup 35 year
old Messi is closing in on his first
global Title
tens of thousands of fans have traveled
to Qatar from Argentina hoping to
witness one of the game's all-time
greats kappa's International career with
football's biggest prize
[Applause]
we see the effort that everyone has made
to come here and be part of the games
and also the people enjoying it from
Argentina I know that all of Argentina
would like to be here but that isn't
possible the unity that we have enjoyed
for a while is very beautiful at every
match it's incredible how they are
living each game and transmitting so
much passion and energy I thank them
because it's incredible
the Netherlands team they'll face in the
quarterfinals certainly enjoyed their
knockout win against the USA at their
last World Cup appearance in 2014 Dutch
fund came to an end with defeat against
Argentina in the last four we know that
you are three games away from Glory you
could be three games away from Glory
and we are
in this position right now and we want
to show we want to perform and give
leave it all on the pitch and hopefully
get success and this is our opportunity
Dutch coach Louis van Hall is another
rallying point for the players he
returned to the job for a third time
last year the 71 year old guiding the
team through World Cup qualification
while also being treated for prostate
cancer
he's a very good guy as well you can
speak to him no more and I think
everyone is good for with him and I
think also because this will be his last
one
um yeah everyone wants to fight for him
and do well for him
Argentina's fans are hoping it will be
their team that can bring the
Netherlands 19-game unbeaten run to an
end Andy Richardson Al Jazeera